where do you find these just crazy
characters that you end up bringing on
the show
the whole thing started with like doing
documentaries and kind of doing like run
and gun style shoes we just filmed like
these crazy people we couldn't even
imagine existed and putting it on
youtube with some of the best content
i've ever worked on it's all stuff that
gives me just like this burning feeling
in my stomach that i know like people
are gonna be mad insane
yeah
you have two three hour shot to
basically get as much out of somebody as
you possibly can and you have to
actually at the same time you have to be
able to communicate well i just wanted
to make it like freakazoids you know
like weird people like i'd find under
rocks like like crazy wacky people
actually i have a guy coming on is the
first guess that i'm gonna have that i
won't be able to publish it on youtube
cause i'll definitely get my channel
deleted who's the person so all right
guys bang bang i've got danny here with
me uh you have one of the wildest
podcasts i think that i've seen in a
long time you go and you find people who
no one knows uh who are kind of on the
fringes of society uh and you try to
bring them to the mainstream i think
it's one of your main focuses uh with
your podcast talk a little bit about uh
where do you find these just crazy
characters that you end up bringing on
the show
thanks man i appreciate that well um
usually i find some of the
the whole thing started with like doing
documentaries and kind of doing like run
and gun style shoots
um and many docs one of my most popular
uh little mini documentaries is called
deckhands and basically we found a
couple guys that were um
drinking natty lights behind a 7-eleven
in a local town near me called madeira
beach
and uh
the guy ended up like taking us to his
boat and showing us his porn collection
and like blasting marilyn manson
at obscene volumes like so the whole
neighborhood could hear and uh normal we
yeah we just filmed like these crazy
people
that we didn't we couldn't even imagine
existed and putting it on youtube and
now i'm trying to like
i've tried to take that same concept and
into a
podcast format where i just find random
crazy people or now i hear about them or
they email me and i just bring them on
and yeah and talk to them like what is
the bar for like crazy enough or or
interesting enough is there some way or
is it just whatever you're personally
interested in just whatever i'm
personally interested in yeah yeah and
as you have found these individuals are
there common themes like you've
literally had everyone from a cia
whistleblower to the sonoa cartel like
analysis um it just seems like they're
all fringe they're all weird but what's
the common uh kind of thread through all
this
there really is no common thread through
all of it honestly i just kind of like
lately it's just been
[Music]
getting introduced to people or learning
about people through like my audience
now because i can only do so much myself
like i can only go out and and seek out
as many people so many people now i rely
a lot on people in my audience people
emailing me you know calling me and
saying hey look into this guy this guy
might be cool and then
taking a chance and learning [ __ ] you
know i mean having people that i would
never be interested in otherwise is
there anybody who has either reached out
or somebody's told you like hey go check
this person out they're just too crazy
you're just like i just can't no no um
recently actually i have a guy coming on
who's who's gonna be is the first guest
that i'm gonna have that i won't be able
to publish it on youtube cause i'll
definitely get my channel deleted what
what who's the person so
um
he is there's a documentary made about
him called mr death okay he
was raised
in
a town in like the midwest and his
basically what happened to him is he got
contracted by all the prisons
to develop
the execution
tactic so like he developed the electric
chair he reinvented the electric chair
to make it so it actually worked and
they didn't have to like electrocute
people ten times before they actually
died
um he actually
redeveloped the gallows um the gas
chambers all the means of execution in
prisons in the u.s like since the 60s
and um
really weird interesting guy but the
part the part about him that sucks is
that why i can't talk put him on youtube
or anything because he doesn't believe
the holocaust is real like he's like he
will die on that thing he's like i don't
think it was real he literally went to
like
uh
he went to
germany and visited all these places and
did studies on it and he
he's very convinced very controversial
and convinced and set in his ways and
that's just a conversation that you
gotta keep off of yeah so
do you think about uh susan and the
youtube team and like what uh uh what
they allow on the platform what they
don't or do you need yeah because i know
shit's gonna be good i know the best
like
with some of the best content the best
documentaries and best projects i've
ever worked on it's all stuff that gives
me just like this burning feeling in my
stomach that i know like people are
going to be mad people are going to be
pissed off same
yeah
you you know but it's also uh part of it
feels like uh i have to learn i i i want
to talk to that person like uh um we had
andrew taton and uh the video is up for
a month
million plus views uh and randomly just
gets taken down one day oh it got taken
down
so i reach out to youtube right and uh
of course they give you no real answers
whatever and then eventually
person we work with the youtube they
start telling us hey there's more or
whatever all the way to come back and
like the time stamps on the video and
they're like hey this is why i get taken
down and obviously we disagree they
don't whatever and so you can choose
like fight it or just say hey whatever
we're going to move on um and what you
find through all of that process is like
you know the number one question i got
from people after we released the
episode
what was he like in person
really all these people had opinions
about a guy
but no one had ever met him no one ever
talked to him so all the people on the
internet who are saying like i like them
i don't like them this that whatever
they never talk to them yeah and so it
was fascinating to me because people who
and like folks that uh you wouldn't
think cared about that stuff whether
they were really successful investors
entrepreneurs you know people in the in
the business world whatever
they wanted to know i see him in the
headlines i see this whatever like what
was he like in person and i think that
goes back to this whole idea of like you
know that it's some people are gonna be
mad but like to some degree you you have
to talk to them like how are you gonna
learn without talking to them right
right right yeah and see like
how their mind works and actually sit
like sitting down with somebody in
person is so much different than like
getting a perspective through the
internet through like the lens of the
internet or all the clips that are on
social media yeah i didn't know i didn't
know the first thing about andrew tate
before the this whole thing went crazy
like i didn't know i had to watch a
couple videos to figure out what he was
all about
um and it seems like he has a legit like
a cult following yeah
and there's a lot of people i think on
the internet that are like this um where
uh you can judge them in long form you
can judge them by you know 20 second
clips or whatever uh but you can take
the same person and depending on how
it's packaged and presented you get
completely different views of people you
ever seen the uh i think it's um i'm
gonna mess it up because i know nothing
about the royal family but uh is it
prince harry or prince william or
whatever the guys and there's this thing
on uh a photo that always goes viral on
twitter and uh instagram and he is
basically looks like he's flicking off
like a crowd but then they have a second
photo and what he's really doing is he
has like three fingers up
but from the side view it looks like
he's flicking them off
and so they're always like hey be
careful what you see on the internet you
know like the photos could be misleading
all this stuff yeah and i always think
of that specific image as like
from the side it looks like he's pissed
he's flicking off the camera flicking
off the crowd all the stuff and then you
turn around and look at him straight on
like
yeah that's a weird thing right that's a
weird thing especially with
not even the internet just celebrities
too like people will be
so infatuated with certain people or
certain celebrities online and when they
meet them in real life it's kind of like
a letdown yeah like these people are
false prophets they're really just
really good at one thing yeah they're
really just humans that are really good
at one thing or really good at like
being loud about certain things and
yeah that's weird when you talk to
somebody like uh you talked to somebody
about the senate uh cinonola uh cartel
yeah and uh that's a topic that most
people in america have no clue about
they don't think about whatever like
walk me through how you think about
learning about a topic like that before
the interview
i'd
to be honest i just watched a couple of
documentaries about something before
like for the the guy who came in for the
sinaloa cartel i've always been super
interested in in that subject like
reading i i you know i don't really read
books but i actually have read a book by
i read a book that was written by pablo
escobar's brother
he was like the accountant for
um the medellin cartel
and that kind of got me interested in a
long time ago never said i mean
everybody watches drug cartel
documentaries for the most part right so
you've seen stuff like that netflix
keeps producing them so somebody's
watching
for real and um there's always stuff
stuff in the headlines regarding that
and i didn't realize like the way it
were like so when i did that recent
documentary with luis
shaparo um he lives in mexico and he
reports on the sinaloa cartel and all
things going on in the cinema cartel i
had like a broad understanding of what
it was a friend of mine just recommended
him to me and when the guy came in i
learned so much about it like this is
how it usually works like when these
people come in and i talk to him
like
i learn so much about that topic i want
to like immediately bring them back and
talk to them again because i've learned
so much from that first interaction with
them
um do you think of it as an interviewers
or a documentary
i think of them as documentaries for
sure like i think of each like
i talked to you before we started i used
to only do documentaries and like
television content and um
when i started doing the podcast i kind
of thought i think of it as a
documentary without the editing and
without the music and without the b-roll
um and what is easier and harder about
the interview versus just a traditional
documentary
the interview is way harder because you
have to be good at talking you have to
be intelligent you have to be
knowledgeable when you're doing a
documentary you're just you're out
you're off camera you can go back and
meet up with this person as many times
like i can go meet up with somebody talk
to them for an hour on camera come back
edit it figure out what's good and where
i want to go from there meet up with
them again
shoot again
go interview other people give it
context
with this it's kind of like one shot you
know like you know but you have a
successful podcast you have two three
hour shot to basically get as much out
of somebody as you possibly can and you
have to actually at the same time you
have to be able to communicate well like
that's something i suck i still suck at
is communication communication
so like being able to play this
ping-pong match of a podcast
and actually draw the right stuff out of
somebody is such a unique talent that uh
i'm trying to get better at but a lot of
people are naturally good at it like
you're naturally good at julian trying
to fire he's amazing at it um but i
think like this
this talent that you develop by doing
this art form
translates to so many different aspects
of life
like what like just anything like
like building relationships like if
you're in if you're in business and you
want to
get new clients if you want to make
people like you if you want to
everything just communication
communicating with humans is i think one
of the most important aspects of of life
yeah that's that's what makes life
better and more enriching yeah it's also
uh interesting that you said uh you
don't read books but you do quite a bit
watching documentaries and then you
obviously talk to people as well is the
books are just boring or
i listen to audiobooks i'm just a slow
reader not very smart uh i dropped out
of college like first year so i don't i
don't i don't know like sitting down
turning pages to me is not something i
don't i have two kids so that that kind
of like gets in the way but like
traveling here i could listen to an
audiobook or you know driving anywhere
or at the gym or something like that
it's easier to listen to podcasts and
audiobooks for me yeah i am so that's
what i did for the last four or five
years was i don't think i read a book i
think i listened to them all on
audiobook and then i've seen a lot of
podcasts and about four months ago i sat
down uh somebody gave me a physical book
i was like that looks interesting and i
sat down to read it
and my head hurt i couldn't read it yeah
and i was like oh this is not good
and like i was like
scared to tell anyone because i was like
oh my god like my brain doesn't work i'm
literally a [ __ ] i can't read a book um
but what i realized was it it wasn't
reading uh you know hopefully i know how
to read it was more so the concentration
yeah and so i started look uh looking
online like why is this happening and
one of the things that
i realized is like when you read a book
uh it is something that doesn't have the
led screen behind it and what has
happened to many of our minds and eyes
and things like that is we never look at
distance
if you're inside all day long you just
have a screen and it's you know two feet
three feet away from your face right
how far do you look maybe you turn to
like your colleague and you look 10 feet
away but you never have to look 50 feet
out in front of you for the most part
and so your eyes aren't used to depth
kind of going back and forth and it's
not used to looking at things other than
an led screen for long periods of time
so it tricks your brain into like not
being able to do it and so then i just
wrote a bunch of physical books and i
was like i'm not going to [ __ ] lose
the ability to like look at a physical
book so for four months that's pretty
much all i've done done no audio i'm
actually not sure i listened to one book
on audio uh when i was running and
things like that um but yeah just been
reading physical books and like now i
feel like a machine but i'm not nearly
as fast as listening on you know one and
a half speed on audio and so i'm scared
to go back because i'm like i build up
this muscle memory but i if i go back to
audio books
what happens do you think you retain
information better when you read it with
your eyes versus listening to it 100
times better really uh yeah i've heard
it makes you you speak and articulate
better too
that wouldn't surprise me i don't know
for sure but like uh i definitely retain
the information better um because like
you know you listen to audiobook and
like maybe your mind wanders a little
bit you're like oh i'm listening to book
um
but maybe it's like 80 retention reading
and it's like 65 with audiobook or 70
it's not that big of a difference but
it's definitely especially around like
uh specific data points or numbers
something like that um
but the other thing is that uh you can't
be doing anything else
right so like with an audio book you can
drive you can uh be at the gym whatever
like you have so much more opportunity
to consume audio in your day then sit
down with a book and like this is all
i'm gonna do right and so like i people
who just sit and read all day like i'm
i'm jealous of them because like that
sounds like a pretty cool life uh but at
the same time like you can't do anything
else i don't know how they're productive
right what when do you find time to do
it i schedule it you do you have to have
you have to be pretty disciplined to do
that right yeah like now especially at
night like i'm like all right at this
point i'm going to sit down with this
book and i'm not getting up for an hour
and a half
and then you know i get mad at myself
like start playing on my phone or
whatever like you just realize like
we're addicted
like we are 100 addicted yeah yeah it's
hard man i mean i only i have a kindle i
read a book on my kindle like earlier
this year but i mean as far as like a
page-turning book like a physical one
i'm telling you if you try to do it and
you can't do it
it's like a mind [ __ ] you're like oh my
god i i have like tricked my brain into
this dopamine
uh like machine yeah where i cannot
stare at just a piece of paper yeah uh
that's gotta be super good for you to
sit down and actually read a book it's
got to be such so good for just like
discipline too to be like carve out an
hour of your day and just sit there in
the quiet
do you have kids yeah i have a uh 10
month old daughter okay but so yes she
she sleeps a lot
okay you're lucky my kids don't sleep
how old are they i have a three year old
and a two week old
two week old yeah there's no sleeping
going on there no no
the when you think of uh a lot of the
guests that you've brought in so if you
look at like somebody like the cia
whistleblower right um
how do you structure what to learn from
them like there's so many different
things that somebody like the cia
whistleblower
that is it just whatever you're
interested in you start asking questions
and three hours later you stop
or do you go into it with a plan that's
what you're going to talk about no
i like are you talking about john
kariaku yeah yeah so with him i had sort
of a rough idea of what i wanted to talk
to him about like i had a couple
rough topics built out in my mind from
the couple documentaries or videos that
i had watched beforehand
um so i had an idea of who he was what
he had done
and what i was interested in before like
i did
a little bit of research on him
obviously
um but like as far as like a structured
framework details of every single
talking point i wanted to hit no not at
all just kind of like let it flow
um
do you let them edit afterwards
like if you record it if they said you
like hey can we take this out oh
absolutely absolutely yeah if anyone
ever if they ever say like i want to cut
that out or sometimes they have like
bathroom breaks in the middle we'll cut
it out it's not a big deal but typically
like 99 of them we don't edit at all
yeah that's how we are as well and uh we
joke that the people who always ask for
something edited are the ones who like
dude nobody cares it rarely happens it
rarely happens right nobody cares about
that one offhand comment but like to
them it really matters like sure dude
yeah i want to kind of get away from i
don't know how i got pigeonholed into
like doing the i've had a few cia people
on the show and i just recently had an
fbi person on the show i don't know how
i spiraled down went down that branch
but do they recommend each other i want
to get away from it yeah uh
no some of them do but usually it's like
the audience will be like yo get this
guy on he'll be really good and it
usually does really good like like if
you look at the metrics and views and
everything like yeah it works good but
i'm not super like into that that's not
like what i wanted to do when i started
the podcast what did you want to do i
just wanted to make it like freakazoids
you know like weird people like fi i'd
find under rocks like like crazy wacky
people not like he said the pitch no
it's like no you're a freakazoid come on
[Laughter]
but i mean yeah no i never imagined it
would go
when you need to think of all of the
people you've been how many episodes
you've done now a hundred and
i've done like i'm like 155 i think okay
who is the one that stands out in your
mind is like the absolute craziest
person you've talked to is it the
deckhands
yeah they weren't podcasts so they were
they were documentaries those are apps a
100 of the craziest people i ever talked
to yeah all right what about on the
podcast form i don't know
i don't know i've been asked this
question i feel like so many times i
really don't know
um
you don't have one that stands out
no i mean one of my favorite episodes
was with he wasn't i mean it wasn't he
was just an author it was tom o'neil the
guy who wrote the charles manson book he
had some crazy stories his story was
fascinating
charles manson is one of those people
that i think a lot of folks around our
age have heard of but they actually
don't know the story
there's a book called cults like
c-u-l-t-s
long story as to how this ended up in my
possession uh but i was reading it and
uh the first 50 pages is the charles
manson story oh really [ __ ] wacky man
wacky [ __ ]
like not i'm not gonna go kill people
but like i'm gonna order people to go
kill people and they're in my cult and
so they listen and like
it's just [ __ ] crazy and i think
there's a whole generation of people who
were like right after
the generation that would that was like
their thing that they lived through that
we don't
could you imagine like if we were i
don't know in our early 20s and there
was like a serial killer doing stuff
like that no it's weird too like his
story i don't know if you're familiar
with tom's book chaos but basically he
ended up doing like a 20
20-year study deep dive on charles
manson he wasn't even interested in it
but he was working for like a he was a
reporter for a magazine and his he got
the assignment to basically just write
an article about like the
ten year anniversary of the uh tate la
bianco murders
and um
he eventually got he got a little bit
you know entrenched in the story and he
kept getting deeper and deeper and
deeper
and um
basically charles manson was like a
two-bit criminal stealing cars and
robbing grocery stores and stuff like
that at like a young age yeah
12 was stealing cars and driving like
across the country right right
driving across state lines which made it
a federal crime but he had a really
[ __ ] up childhood too like a really
[ __ ] up childhood getting moved
between like orphanages and uh foster
care yeah and then he was like basically
a professional criminal because he just
kept learning from other people right
like all the different crimes to commit
and then like tom eventually talked to a
bunch of his probation officers and he
found out that he kept getting let out
of prison they kept getting let out and
let out and let out and kept talking to
these people and there's like there it
makes no sense how he kept getting out
of jail
for after he had been in so many times
for so many different crimes
and then um well like at some point
society has to say like can we really
keep the 15 year old
right
yeah like maybe we should maybe we
should i don't know what the answer is
but like i got to imagine that the age
if you're like
a young teenager
someone somewhere it's like ah i feel
bad for the 14 year old who got arrested
and you know we gotta let them out you
think maybe they just thought he was
unmanageable so they let him out
no it's like uh
imagine today like you can just
twitter something goes viral and it's
like 12 year old locked up for stealing
a car yeah and the mob would show up and
be like let them out
right
and they'd be like you know you can't
treat 12 year olds like this that's
inhumane like all the stuff now they
didn't have social media and stuff back
then but like it's the same sentiment of
if you just look at the one event
then like uh
like that's 12 year old everyone does
dumb stuff as 12 years old like yeah
sure i didn't steal cars and like drive
across state lines and stuff but like
every 12 year old did something dumb
but then when you look at the totality
of it right and you're like hey by the
way he was doing this since like 6.
and had done it like 20 times by the
time he was 15. that's obviously a
different story but like yeah do judges
and stuff like that really
back then have all that information i
don't know
yeah it's weird too but he was a lot
older like he was doing it from super
young age like into his mid 20s yeah 30s
right yes and then like the connection
with but he kept getting let out in his
teens which almost like reinforced oh
you just do it you go to jail and then
come back out right right right and then
the connection with between that and
the um the clinic in san francisco that
free clinic that he that he was
basically bringing everybody to and they
were giving them lsd like that gets
crazy with mk ultra being connected to
it and mind control and
the whole thing with the 60s the rev you
know the hippies protesting against the
vietnam
fascinating book man well the part to me
uh that also becomes like kind of wild
is um
i guess at one point there was some
murders that people in the cult carried
out uh and then there was another one
but they wrote if i understand correctly
uh the same thing on the wall
yeah in like blood
and they were trying to write something
that would like make it look like it was
another group committing the murders
but
they wrote the same thing on the wall
and and the cops like didn't put two and
two together at first yeah and so like i
always just go back to like
how advanced so many aspects of society
are now with the internet
right like if you're a cop and there's
somewhere buried in like a paper police
report
some detail like something was written
on the wall
how do you know if you're a different
cop that shows up to a different crime
scene right in the you know 60 70s
whatever like
now we're like oh you idiots like how
did you not know that right but you're
like yeah dude like it was on paper we
just talked about like read a book
[Laughter]
right like what cop was sitting there
gonna go through the police reports yeah
man the incompetence is crazy right like
now you would now if that was if the
story was like that was published online
there would be somebody in twitter just
like noticing it and posting it and it
would get retweets and people would see
it
but
back then before the internet before the
days of the internet it had to be
so
so much more difficult to kind of link
[ __ ] like that i bet so much
so many things like that slipped through
the cracks yeah and the reverse happens
right like how many times do we hear
stories now some you know uh person was
locked up for 20 years and then it's
like oh now we have dna testing like
innocent yeah how crazy is that
hey guys uh dna testing's been around
for a while like how did we not figure
that out you know five ten years ago
yeah dude that's insane i just had a guy
on my show recently too who did like 16
years in prison and they found him he
was exonerated because of dna they
usually found the guy who committed the
rape and murder um
16 years later
and they brought that guy to jail and
then found out that his dna was the
correct dna oh so they arrested somebody
for something else
had the dna taken and then
cross-referenced it exactly realized
wait a minute this guy actually
committed this crime not the person
who's sitting in jail exactly jesus
christ and i think the guy only got like
i can't remember exactly i want to say
it was like four million bucks
he did 16 years in prison and got like
four or five million bucks most of it
which had to go to his attorneys
but could you imagine 16 years in prison
for something you didn't do and i think
like even they even found
a ton of evidence at the site of the
murder that didn't even come close to
matching this guy like it clearly
depicted somebody of a different
ethnicity than him oh wow and uh they
still just wanted to get there get it
wash their hands of it and get their
prosecution
the two things it makes me think of um
is uh was making a murder on the the
netflix uh oh yeah i forgot about the
episodic series i always just think when
they have like the 16 17 year old boy uh
in the uh room with the cops and the
cops are like basically saying all this
stuff and they're getting to confess and
then once he gets done he's like uh um
am i gonna go back to school now
and they're like
nah dude
like no
and then he's like on the phone or
something with i think his mom uh or a
relative and he's like asking is he
gonna get let out for wrestlemania so
you could like watch it on tv and like
he has no
like you're just like listening to him
talking you're like this kid does not
understand that he just admitted to a
murder which maybe he did or did not
commit
yeah he has no clue right none
what do you think about like the rise of
this was making a murder we talked about
like the drug cartel documentaries and
that type of stuff but also uh serial
the podcast um that it uh i forget the
guy's name um who is the
supposed uh suspect
who i think had been arrested during all
of that i just saw now even the
prosecutors
are saying hey we got some more
information uh we should uh let this guy
out uh because there's like a
we don't have as much confidence
in him being the person as we once did
it's like how do you think about the
rise of all this like crime content dude
the crime content's crazy
some of the most popular content in the
world i i i tell uh my buddy one of my
buddies who comes on the show every once
in a while who has a lot of friends in
prison i told them that they need to get
some microphones in there and start
their own like in prison podcast because
they would make so much [ __ ] money it
would explode can you imagine like
they're in like uh uh it can't be
maximum security prison right you
couldn't get microphones in but like
maybe i don't know anything about being
in prison but yeah i mean if you're in
one of those camps they have cell phones
so i wouldn't be able to get mics you
know at least i'm like small mics that's
what i'm saying so like they have to be
somewhere where they have some sort of
communication yeah like even i mean i
think how much money that the the prison
owners would make
like if you if you owned a prison
if i went to prison i would set up my
own podcast studio i'd have multiple i'd
get them in there just churning out
podcasts every day bro are you kidding
me they there is other work that is done
right but like in in some way also um
did you see uh
uh who was it um i think actually two
guys i did it i don't think shrek rally
at martin shrek rally uh the pharma bro
uh i don't think he did a podcast but um
the guy from fire festival billy
mcfarlane oh yeah i think at some point
they like
snuck a microphone in or maybe he was on
the phone like he was doing like the
call and they were recording it and he
was um oh actually i actually know the
guy who did it now i think about it um
they called it dumpster fire
and he was calling and they were
recording it they were turning into a
podcast and then he got put in um uh he
got put in the hole oh no uh for like
participating in a podcast no permission
yeah i mean if you think about it right
like i guess that's kind of the whole
thing is like it's all about control
if you're like going to the phones and
participating in uh in podcasts yeah
everybody's fascinated with people in
prison like people are just always
there's like always reporters in there
trying to get calls or trying to get in
one-on-one interviews with prisoners and
learn their stories because like those
are some of the i mean honestly those
people are probably some of the most
interesting people in the world yeah do
you know what a show i feel like uh we
probably had which was much it seems
like much more popular when we were
younger is cops
remember like the cops would like they
would have somebody with a full video
camera uh and like a whole video crew
like following them around and sometimes
like they pulled somebody over other
times it was like bam foot chase like
whatever they do that live now you know
that no they have live cops
where like there's i don't know how live
it is but i'm sure there's some sort of
time delay so they don't just like cut
to a cop they probably just put a live
logo on there shooting someone or
something right but they the way they
presented is like there's a command
center
and there's like two guys or whatever
and they're like oh let's go out to
tulsa
oklahoma you know
officer whoever
like it's like like it's like a red zone
right but like rather than drop into
like the dolphins game like let's drop
into tulsa oklahoma we're riding shotgun
with officer whatever
just [ __ ] crazy um
and they like record these interactions
is there any proof that it's actually
live
are they allowed
it's on tv so like i can't imagine it's
100 real time live like maybe there's a
time delay they're getting desperate
something's going on tv executives are
getting desperate they're saying let's
call it cops live and put a [ __ ]
flashing red light under it and call it
live i guarantee you yeah and like is
there
uh could you get in trouble if you're
the executive for saying it's live
probably not no hell no right like if
you were just like whatever it is the
content good yeah they could sell it as
long as they can sell it and make more
money they they'll get away with it so
uh you like watch it and like
it's just a whole different view of the
world
because you see yeah they go into
people's houses and you're just like
oh my god this house is just full of
trash or like these people are hoarders
or uh these people there's a domestic
dispute and you're just like dude that
is a chaotic life that like is
unfortunate that anyone has to live
through yeah and it's just this lens and
you forget like that's on like
you know uh uh cable networks like
that's not on you know uh uh hbo or
anything like that like if you just have
cable
watch it's on fox
or whatever dude on the way here on 95
right before i turned uh to go to
downtown there was literally a car i
think it was like a
honda civic pulled on the side of the
interstate side of the highway
dude was like aggressively beating the
[ __ ] out of somebody in the backseat of
his car like full-on haymakers
the car was pulled over welcome to miami
all right the cars pulled over on the
side of the road pulled off from the
side of the road literally right like
right bef before or i think right after
an exit okay on 95 95 south
and this dude was [ __ ] had both doors
open and he was aggressively [ __ ]
wailing on him in the front seat he was
back when he was out he was standing on
the ground outside on the road and he
was punching into the car beating the
[ __ ] out of somebody
and no one was laughing nobody was
stopping
i mean
are you surprised miami's stopping no
i'm not surprised i'm not surprised at
all right now that's not something you
typically see in tampa when you see that
you know you're in miami
is that how people who live in the tampa
area think of miami is like miami's
where the crazy [ __ ] happens maybe i
live i don't really live in tampa i live
on the beach i live on indian rocks
beach so yeah when you think of miami
you think of like another country really
i mean it's not really the united states
the rest of the country now also thinks
of miami as another country probably
right
people who still live in california or
new york
the traffic here is way worse than
california you think yes
i don't know if i'd agree with that like
la probably not la's the only place in
the world where there's like eight lanes
and it's still bumper-to-bumper traffic
right right so like maybe outside of la
and other parts of california yeah miami
traffic could be bad but also like rush
hour in new york is pretty bad as well
maybe not new york yeah you're not i'm
not you're right so like in the downtown
areas right or like uh uh on the la
highway
maybe those areas are worse but yes
traffic especially on like the lower end
of 95 can get pretty bad yeah when i got
off of 95 it said i was literally going
to be here in like 10 minutes and i was
not here for like another 30 40 minutes
this place is [ __ ] crazy man yeah
well i love miami by the way also uh
when it rains here it just floods oh
yeah
like uh uh recently there was a rain um
and i was at a restaurant uh on south
beach um with three other guys we were
sitting it's like a window
uh to right in the sidewalks on the
other side of the window and i'm sitting
with my back to the window and also the
guy's like dude it's really pouring
outside so i turn and i look and
definitely raining a lot but nothing out
of the ordinary yet and
20 minutes later he's like dude now look
and i turned and i look and the water
was starting to like rise on the road
and i was like oh that's kind of crazy
but like whatever we still got like
another hour at dinner like maybe it'll
get better dumb idea uh so then like
half an hour later he's like dude it's
over the curb
and i look and i swear the water was
literally over the curb uh like kind of
like peeking over and so uh this
specific restaurant there's nowhere to
park so it's all valet for the most part
and when people were leaving the
restaurant they were pulling the cars up
onto the sidewalk so we would get in the
car without having to go in their ankle
deep water you know they get their gucci
shoes away and i was just like
dude these guys are pros like like there
was no uh what do we do it was just like
oh we probably deal with this like once
a week so i like to drive the cars up on
the sidewalk what happens to the parking
garages that are underground that go
down like do they get completely flo
like are those underwater what happens
to those parking garages no i'm sure
that they've got some sort of drainage
and
you would hope now again i'm sure
there's somewhere where that's not true
uh over a couple blocks over in brickell
um
there's one area there's a publix and
it's like notorious when it rains really
bad it floods so if you remember a
couple months ago there was all these
videos of people like leaving the club
at like two o'clock in the morning and
they were like falling in the water
there was cars that were like hitting uh
uh uh huge holes because at the time
they're doing construction right there
it's there's like a hole in the ground
but it was like uh
they the cones and everything so during
the day no one i mean you'd have to be
an idiot to somehow end up in the
construction hole mm-hmm but when the
water had risen up no it was there so
there's a car with like its front left
tire had like gone in and so is that
like a vertical thing and i was just
thinking to myself i'm like dude i'm so
glad that i'm not going to like clubs
and walking out and oh my god knee high
water what brought you to miami like how
did you end up here
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i drink ag-1 by athletic
greens every single day i started it out
a couple of years ago and i liked it so
much that i even became an investor in
the business every single day rather
than take a bunch of pills for vitamins
and minerals i simply take one scoop of
ag-1 in a glass of water it gives me 75
vitamins minerals probiotics superfoods
and adaptogens i really really like it
because it's so simple if you go and you
sign up at athleticgreens.com
today they will give you one year of
immune supporting vitamin d for free and
they will also give you five free travel
packages go to
athleticgreens.com today to get started
stop taking all those vitamin and
mineral pills and just take one scoop of
ag1
athleticgreens.com go check them out
today i'm still trying to figure that
out
uh no i was in new york uh
i think we just wanted to leave new york
like you're so you're born and raised in
new york uh i was actually born in
hollywood florida oh okay and then grew
up in north carolina uh i went live in
california for a little bit and then i
was in new york and i mean new york
i love will always love uh but like
it just started to decline to some
degree right it was very similar to
california right um and i think that's
why you saw like the net move out of
those two states right into places like
texas or florida is that when you moved
here i moved uh
we decided in november of 2020 we moved
the first week of january okay
and so uh
there were people here from like the
business tech kind of investing world
right but it wasn't a lot yet
and then like march april may of 2021 it
was like every single person i knew was
like i'm thinking about moving to miami
and i was like oh [ __ ] like this was a
great decision yeah um and uh i think
the biggest difference frankly like in
hindsight is people are just happier in
florida
like i don't know if it's the sun i
don't know if it's like you go outside
more yeah if it's not like you feel
cramped because the building what for
whatever reason like people see much
it's similar to new york right here
though like this downtown miami yes
brickell area is is not really florida
yeah that's why uh i think a lot of
folks from new york when they come uh
they basically move to like two areas
kind of a midtown ish area um and then
brickell at first because it's the most
like manhattan or new york and then from
there they kind of spread out to
wherever they're going to go after a
little while but it's like you don't
want to like rip the band-aid off
imagine going from like i don't know
uh
you know lower east side to like montana
right
you'd be like all right it's a little
weird
so i don't know
yeah man i feel like
tampa and and where i'm from like the
beaches are are are so much more rural
and open and even though they're not
they're still kind of like little cities
but there's nothing like miami like
like where i live you can just you can
drive down the beach
there it's wide open there's not really
many high-rises except for like on the
edge of the beaches like all the condos
and stuff in tampa uh there's a um
uh netflix show now on uh like selling
sunset but it's uh selling tampa have
you seen oh really oh yeah i had no idea
and it's all about like some brokerage
just like blowing up or whatever um and
uh
uh
they're positioning it as like tampa's
you know on the come up is that true i
think so tom brady's there
uh the lightning
apparently i don't know anything about
hockey but i know like the lightning are
all the rage right now um
do people in tampa you got the best
strip clubs
according to who according to the world
tampa is the strip club capital of the
world that's not true yeah is it really
yeah they're way better than the ones in
miami no but like is there like a strip
club ranking yeah there is if you even
google google it like if you just search
for like i'm sure he can do it but if
you search for like america's top strip
clubs the top like two or three are in
tampa
i've had the guy who owns the most
famous uh strip club in the world on my
show too really yeah what did he say uh
he was just what makes it so famous he
so he it's the he was the first strip
club in i believe the
maybe in the u.s i could be wrong might
be just in florida but he was the first
full nude strip club
ah legally full nude and he had to fight
the city and the government forever yeah
and now he's doing this whole new thing
where he can he's like now he's fighting
he's suing the government to like grow
his own marijuana because he has cancer
and he's using it for medicinal purposes
but he's a [ __ ] he's a badass like he
would be out in the street like fighting
with cops and like protesting with the
protesters
because i guess it was um
i think it
it was like a free speech debate right
for to be able to have the strippers
there and then tampa tried to create the
the mayor of tampa tried to institute a
law where
if you got a lap dance the stripper had
to be
like five feet away from you like it had
to be a five foot distance to get a lap
dance two weeks to flatten the curve
yeah yeah yeah
and he fought it to the death and uh and
yeah so what's fascinating to me is like
a lot of these uh folks are real estate
investors that's how they actually get
started uh there's some guys here in
miami who uh they own like 11 which is
like a club
you know got some other things going on
um and uh they back into it cause
they're like buying properties and then
like some of them are zoned for
strip clubs or clubs or you know liquor
licenses whatever um but i never
realized how much they fight with the
city council and the local government
and like all that stuff is like a whole
new world you mean once you own like
commercial real estate which is like
think of these real estate developers
like tampa obviously has strip clubs now
that i know that uh but also bars or
whatever like a lot of that business is
dealing with local regulations and yeah
understanding okay uh they're gonna put
this through street and uh they won't
put a red light outside
and so like does that increase you know
think of your a bar like a super extreme
example would be like hey you're trying
to petition to get a red light put
outside uh so people will stop because
you're drunk patrons leaving at night
and you want them to be able to cross
the street safely so you don't take on
more legal liability uh for owning a
place that's selling alcohol and so he
goes i think it's hit by a car
but like
you don't get to put the red light up
right right like there's like you gotta
go through a process and then there's
like the other side of it which is like
the city's telling you that you can't do
something or in this case like hey you
can't have a strip club or whatever yeah
it's just like this battle yeah it's
crazy like if you want it's interesting
to think like once you even just like if
you're thinking small like people that
don't want to be like big shots or be
like dealing with government or about to
say i want to own some real estate i
want to make some money but you un
unknowingly get into
political [ __ ] once you own bigger more
and more real estate because now you
have to deal with the government now you
have to deal with these regulations and
fight them and try to schmooze people
and take people out to dinner and of
course
one of the things uh a real estate a
very large real estate investor to me
one time he goes uh half the job
is knowing who's responsible for what in
the local government and being able to
get them to do it yeah
and when he said that i was like holy
[ __ ] like i thought it was just you know
you'd run some numbers and like buy a
building
but he was like no he's like that's
actually the important stuff because
then you get into like uh from an
investment perspective there's
opportunity zones so like i don't know
if you know about these but you can
basically invest in certain
predetermined areas and if you hold the
real estate for 10 years it's tax-free
all the gains oh really
you know who created this law who sean
parker
sean parker is the guy uh you ever seen
um the social network the facebook video
movie yeah the guy who helps zuckerberg
uh who's played by justin timberlake
that's sean parker who also started
napster oh no [ __ ] he like teamed up
with this other guy and i think it was
during um i can't remember if it was
right at the end of obama's term or
right when trump got office but it's
like right around that 2014 to like 2016
period um and they basically convinced
the federal government
to create the opportunity zones and the
whole idea is like hey there's parts of
every city that is underinvested and
like if we incentivize investors through
tax breaks to invest in those areas
we'll like improve them
it's like theoretically makes sense yeah
it makes sense but the incentive is like
if you buy property and hold it for 10
years you don't pay any taxes on the
gates oh wow well that's what every real
estate investor does right they're just
trying to fight the loopholes that's
what keeps it going yeah they're just
trying to like the 1031 exchange you
know buy and sell it and reinvest the
profits and move on to something bigger
i mean that's what keeps the whole
[ __ ] gravy train moving really it's
just people trying to find the holes and
to beat the next guy yeah i um uh i saw
an investor on twitter recently giving a
uh a crash course to somebody who's
asking them questions and this guy is
very sophisticated he was explaining a
cash out refi and how like the
difference between what you bought the
property for what uh you get the refi at
like that money is tax-free and like you
could just see this person was like what
do you mean you get hundreds of
thousands of dollars you don't pay taxes
on it he's like i was like part of the
loan
and i was like watching this in real
time and then i went back and then like
later he was like sharing threads to
like a whole real estate account that
was talking about you know segregation
studies
it's a whole different world yeah that's
crazy there's so many ways to make money
there's so many so many different crazy
weird ways to make money but like real
estate is the one thing that's like it
doesn't take a lot to understand it it's
just like hard work if you have if you
put in the hard work and you and you
meet the right people you can
make pretty much anything you want to
happen in real estate yeah you don't
have to have like some sort of special
knowledge you could be nobody you could
have know nothing
and you can i think it's more than 50 of
millionaires in the united states made
it through real estate really yeah i
mean
i'm assuming and again big assumption
i'm assuming a portion of that is
literally just uh including their
primary residence so if you bought a
house 20 years ago for 100 grand and now
it's worth 300 000 like that's 30 of the
way to being a millionaire right so like
there's some of that going on um but
yeah real estate by far is an asset
class that probably helps mint more
uh millionaires anybody else what do you
think about people like that guy grant
cardone who like tried to sell all these
real estate courses and they'd like
project their wealth and stuff because
that guy's always around my town like
he's always in he bought a lot of stuff
in tampa i think oh did he really i
think he bought i might get this wrong
i'm pretty sure that he bought like a
pretty big uh
like um 500 unit apartment complex or
something oh really but he does this
weird thing where he like sells his
youtube subscribers
he gets his youtube followers to
invest in his properties
yeah i so i have a lot of thoughts about
this um i think this is where the world
is going but i think it's also like very
uncharted waters right so like if you
think about uh go to the other extreme
like if you're uh i don't know blackrock
or blackstone let's use blackstone as an
example uh you're a huge you know
billions and billions and billions of
dollars
of assets when you want to raise a fund
what do you do you like
take the idea you put in some documents
you put together a pitch deck and then
you go to all these institutions and you
show up to hospitals uh university
endowments
foundations pension funds like all these
huge pools of capital
so like when people think of like a
pension fund you think of like oh i work
for like a city or something i'm putting
my money into the pension and then
they're gonna like invest it and then
when i retire they're gonna pay me out
whatever the money is like where do they
invest it like sure some of it's in the
stock market but usually the pension
fund is not the one like
to buy apple or walmart today
right they're giving it to
investors they're giving it to managers
right and so they'll turn around and
they'll say like hey we have two billion
dollars in our pension fund for name
your city in america and they'll be like
hey blackstone we'll give you 25 million
dollars for your real estate fund or for
your hedge fund or whatever
so they're like raising money
through
these institutions but really in many of
those cases the institution's actually
managing money for like the individual
right the pension fund is actually
that's not the pension fund's money it's
the pensioneers money that they're
supposed to be growing until people
retire right
just like in every other part of society
where like middlemen are getting cut out
i think what you're starting to see is
people realize well why don't we just
cut out those middlemen those
institutions and go direct to people
right now
the positives are there's a lot of folks
who want access to
institutional real estate or you know
stocks or venture capital or whatever
the downside is like there's a hell of a
lot of risk
right so you get kind of pros and cons
with it and um
it's less about like what do i think is
it like is it good or bad it's just like
it's gonna happen and it's gonna
accelerate
and so we have accreditation laws right
where you have to be an accredited
investor you have to have a certain net
worth or make a certain amount of money
every year
the positive is like that's supposed to
protect you the downside is like i know
a lot of dumb rich people right who like
you know uh
doctors i've talked to a lot of doctors
and they're like dude my colleagues they
don't know anything about investing but
they make four or five hundred thousand
dollars a year right it's a lot of cash
so like you know they all think that
they're going to find the next facebook
so they like angel and fast
and it's like yeah they all think that
18 year old kid that lives in their
neighborhood and you're like dude the
odds that you happen to live next to the
next mark zuckerberg right like
negative percent
right
um but like if that's been celebritized
and so in some way it's just like that's
what's going on it's like they're like
okay let me pick the manager um
that's interesting why what do you think
i don't know i don't know anything about
it i just know the guy is always flying
in and out of clearwater going to the uh
the scientology center and he's walking
up and down like downtown clearwater
like talking to his phone and i've seen
him literally like talking to his phone
walking like up and down right in front
of the scientology center before what
what is the scientology center do you
know yeah it's the it's like the
hub of scientology i've never been
inside or you are not grew up like five
minutes away from it are
non-scientologists i think it's right
term uh allowed to go inside no i don't
think so so you gotta be like unless you
like wanna like actually sign up and
learn about it like you could fake
wanting to you could like get in there
if you faked not knowing anything about
it and like ooh i want to get into this
but normal people are like i'm shocked
that you live five minutes and you
haven't done that video yet no no
[ __ ] i'm too afraid of
i'm trying i don't i don't know anything
about it but it seems like uh uh
yeah there's like because tom cruise i
think is one that's tom cruise yeah tom
cruise um i think he has an apartment
right across the street from there in
clearwater um john travolta a bunch of
people oh john travolta is in too yeah
he's in the uh
in the crew the club yeah he's a
scientologist man the thing is but it's
a religion it's not it's technically a
legal religion yeah they um you why
technically well it's it's i mean i
guess it's legitimately a religion it's
not just technically religion but the
reason the reason it became a religion
was because they wanted to be tax-free
so they had they they did this crazy
thing where they had like all of their
members like tens and tens of thousands
of people file their own individual
lawsuits against the irs
and basically bullied the irs into
giving them of the relig the religion
exemption that's real yeah that's real
oh i didn't know that there's a crazy
documentary on hbo called um scientology
the prison of belief
and he talks about this specifically oh
yeah it goes into all of it like the the
top guys who are into scientology right
next to like the like the vice president
of scientology literally like defected
went away from it and he basically
explained everything that happened wow
it's wild and the head of sciento the
guy who created it l ron hubbard
he um he died i think in like the 80s
but he was also the most prolific
non-fiction writer of all time he's
wrote more non-fiction than anybody in
history and he
so basically the premise of scientology
there's this galactic overlord named
xenu
who um
spawned some some race out of a volcano
and um
there's these
spirit entities that exist called
uh thetans that are like these
non-physical entities that you can't see
that can get come in or get out of you
depending on how clear you are in
scientology so the more you learn the
crazier the more deep you get into
scientology like there's levels just
like a pyramid scheme
and once you get to like the top level
they start teaching you about this crazy
intergalactic sci-fi things like sci-fi
[ __ ] that
would scare any normal person away if
they saw that at space value
what do you think all these guys are
in or so many like john travolta tom
cruise grant cardone well they got in it
i think i think the
most of the people got in it because i
think there's a lot of value in the
like the dot the book dianetics like
it's basically like being the best
version of yourself optimizing yourself
getting rid of all the negative
influences in your life there's a lot of
like positive
psychological elements to
the premise of scientology to dianetics
to basically
help people become the best version of
themselves they can possibly become but
once you get past that like you get into
that you start to like pay some money
for the fees some of these people pay
hundreds of thousands of dollars to keep
rising the ranks they get stuck and they
feel like they're part of something
bigger than themselves you know and um
once you get to a certain level they
start saying okay now you're
aware enough to
read the next chapter and then they
start to bring in the crazy crazy
more crazy and crazy [ __ ]
and uh
another weird part of it is there's this
thing called auditing that you have to
do when you're inside college so you
have to go and do this thing called
auditing where you go in basically to a
room and you hold these two metal rods
and this person asks you questions about
your personal life and you
basically spill your guts about
everything in your life all the most
[ __ ] up things you've done your worst
thoughts you've ever had
and they keep detailed records of all
this [ __ ] and i think that's probably
what happened with tom cruise then with
john travolta as they probably you know
told them their deca deepest darkest
secrets and they don't want those to be
to be made public
i feel like if it came out like they
could say anything about tom cruise
people but yep uh okay
yeah i think so too
i don't know what it is i think they
basically like most people in
scientology get
they get kept on some sort of unleashed
where they're not allowed to interact
with people of the outside world or any
anyone with like dissenting views or
ideologies like if there's anybody
there's rules like if you talk to
somebody who's
not
cool that was uh scientology it's like a
it's like a trouble it's a community of
snitches so they all spy on each other
and they all tell on each other so if
you see somebody doing something that's
not
like
by the rule book of scientology they go
and snitch on them and then you get in
trouble and you go
i had actually i had the um the dad of
the
see the head of scientology david
miscavige in my podcast oh really i had
his dad on there is his dad in no his
dad wasn't but he was like he was like
imprisoning his dad and his dad escaped
like like literally it was like a prison
break type thing what yeah bro it is it
is absolutely his dad's saying bananas
his dad was basically explaining his
childhood um
you know his son was really young really
he was super motivated super intelligent
and um he went to go work for l ron
hubbard who was the guy who founded
scientology in hollywood like working on
film sets and stuff like that
and eventually just became l ron
hubbard's right hand man like his
assistant
and then um
eventually elrond hubbard died and david
miscavige just took over you know he
just had it in him to just he was this
leader this leader yeah he had this
strong personality and he made everyone
follow him and
um i don't think he's been in the public
light for years now because of all the
stuff that's come out recently i mean
there's there's tons of documentaries
and tv shows of people that have left
scientology talking about how [ __ ] up
it is inside and
um
you know there's people being held like
slaves being held in the building in
clearwater that people that were there
stuck there for years that they weren't
allowed to do anything like they were
literally kept in rooms and
they had to work for free and they
weren't allowed to leave
it's scary [ __ ] i saw a documentary on
um
what's the church uh they go and they
like protest uh
um all sorts of like uh maybe it's like
abortion clinics they go and they
protest um uh like when soldiers die i
think uh what westborough
is that uh oh yeah right like they go
and they protest and yeah
and there was a woman who uh
uh had defected i guess
and uh and she was talking about it and
it was she was like
i believed every single like all these
things and they were like showing her
videos of herself and she was like
holding signs and i forgot what they
were saying but the signs were just like
when you look at the sign as a person
with my background or your background
right and and not having grown up in
that environment you're like that's like
crazy stuff yeah dude it's crazy like
what she was saying she's like no you
don't understand like i believed that in
that video that's not me
yeah
yeah it's crazy when you get sucked into
[ __ ] like that like if that just becomes
everything to you it's you and you
believe something it feels right like
you think you're doing the right thing
yeah you don't have an outside
perspective i always think of uh
whenever i see stories in the news um
intention
like
people can do
good things
by accident like they weren't trying to
do good right uh they actually could be
like nefarious actors who like
[ __ ] up and somehow did something good
uh or somebody could be
good intention trying to do the right
thing and they do something wrong
and it if you just like read an article
you're never gonna know but like there
are certain stories that blow up where
um if you think of uh take fire festival
as an example
like an entire generation of people know
it as like this huge screw-up right a
kid gets in trouble like all this type
of stuff
but it's like when i look at that i'm
like
based on the information that we have
was that person trying to do the right
thing or not and we'll never know
the answer right right but like
if you knew definitively like that was
uh someone trying to do something
nefarious you'd think of it very
differently of than if you knew
definitively like that person was trying
to be a good person and like do the
right thing and like they just [ __ ] it
up right right and uh
what becomes interesting about this is
you then look at these situations uh i
don't know if you saw a couple weeks ago
there's a guy in indiana who ran into a
burning building uh burning house he's a
food delivery guy you see this i didn't
see this he's driving down the street
and uh all of a sudden he sees uh smoke
coming out of a house he's like that was
that was weird he stops he backs up and
he looks he's like oh [ __ ] that house is
on fire so he like runs towards the
house uh and somehow gets the back door
i don't know if he couldn't get in the
front door or what but he gets the back
door and i think he like busted into the
house
and he's like holy [ __ ] there's like
flames and there's smoke everywhere like
all this stuff and so he starts yelling
yelling yelling whatever and he starts
going up uh
some stairs and as he's going upstairs
all of a sudden there's three or four
kids like under the age of like 12
all sudden come busting out of a room
and he like grabs them and he like takes
them to the back door and gets them out
and he says to them he's like is there
anybody else in the house and they're
like uh our little sister i think and
he's like where and like she's inside
she's inside she's six
so this [ __ ] savage goes back into
the burning house and he like
is he's uh i think what happens is he
goes upstairs he finds her and he comes
back down but he's lost now he doesn't
know where the back door is so he's
stuck in the house
so at some point he like looks up and he
sees the stairs and there's like light
so he goes back up the stairs and he
goes to a window and he punches out the
window when he punch out the window
obviously he cuts up his whole arm and
everything and he jumps off the second
story with this little girl and uh
the reason why the story got so much
attention was the police are showing up
at this point they all have the body
cams on and so they're like showing up
and of course they're like there's
somebody inside and like the
firefighters are like
not moving as fast as you would think
they would be doing someone's inside uh
but there's like chaos or whatever and
also here comes this guy running around
the side of the house and he's got this
little girl and he like collapses into
the police arms hands the baby and he
and he falls on the ground and they have
his arm blurred out in the video so you
know it's got to be bad if they're like
blurring it
and the first words he says to the cops
he goes is a little girl okay
he didn't give a [ __ ] about his arm like
and you just like watching you're like
99 out of 100 times that dude is a good
dude who just acted in the moment and
went and like did this
and you can tell because you have video
you hear the stories like all the
details there's other people there
whatever
but we don't always get that and so to
me it's like this fascinating uh example
where like
normally
we just get like a little snippet we
don't get the body cam footage we don't
get to hear what the kids said or
anything it's just like oh somebody did
something and we're just left to like
i don't know they say a good person says
bad person like i don't know
you know it's so different now i thought
you're going somewhere else with this
without you're gonna tell me that this
guy was like a child molester or
something
no no but it's just like in that moment
like you know the hero is the person you
least expect right it's like the pizza
delivery guy who's like just driving
down uh randomly right and it goes back
to this whole thing of just like
man that's somebody who just like was
trying to do the right thing i think
generally people want to do the right
thing you think yeah i think generally i
think people get caught up like get lost
in it like the fire festival guy i think
he was
genuinely trying to make that [ __ ] work
don't you yeah i think so like i think
he basically like
got in a little bit over his head and
[ __ ] started hitting the fan he's like
try to do everything in his possible
reach to make that [ __ ] work yeah and it
obviously didn't work i don't think
people really want to [ __ ] people over i
mean i think sometimes they get backed
into a position where they they really
have no choice i feel like pick the less
or the two evils but
it's also um if you go back to like uh
uh when all the ppp uh loans were coming
out um i have a friend who he works in
uh uh credit right and he was like
was that social security and he was like
now is the time when the fraud is gonna
start and i was like what and he was
like yeah he was like a lot of people
don't realize that like all the
fraudulent stuff around loans and all
that type of stuff um is because people
get desperate
right right so he was like you know and
this is like second hand but he was
basically like yeah like a lot of times
if you go and you look at you know some
major corporation or something uh or
somebody who was trying to get one of
these ppp loans or whatever uh they like
oh let me change this one detail this
one time
next you know spiral's out of control
and so like i don't know
it also makes you think um how much
social media like exasperates all of
this
right like yeah many of these stories a
guy in indiana
if we were living 50 years ago like you
and i wouldn't even heard of it
right right because it wasn't in our
local paper
and it wasn't on a local radio
or maybe local television
now that [ __ ] went [ __ ] viral yeah
right people in other countries know
about this random dude in indiana and so
like
it just
it's like steroids the stories yeah i
mean individuals definitely you know
like people like that you see stories
like that with individual people because
like if you're by yourself and you see
something really bad happening or you
see someone suffering i feel like
there's just this
this thing in our nature to help people
but the polar opposite of that
look you went to iraq right
so
like the military-industrial complex
starting wars killing tons of innocent
people just to make tons and tons of
[ __ ] profit and tons of money like
you think of all those people in the
government dick cheney and all the
bureaucrats in the u.s government that
the
the arms dealers that were making
billions of dollars like there's this
diffusion of responsibility when you get
caught up in this giant system where
it's just like this competition for
money i also i also think a lot about
like local decisions global decisions so
like let's say that we're in a
corporation with 10 000 people and you
and i are like customer service reps
right
we have no ability to make global
decisions like for the entire
corporation entering that type of stuff
we're only local decision makers so like
maybe i make some decisions on calls
that differ from yours or maybe the same
or whatever
maybe we become a manager of like a team
of like five to ten people and we can
make some local decisions for that team
but like the local decision makers have
almost no impact on like what happens to
corporation or kind of the global
the reverse is also true
which seems weird because like
the ceo and a lot of these like large
organizations they can make very big you
know decisions but like their their
ability to control the decision making
that happens like on the phone with a
customer service rep
very hard right right like it goes back
to the diffusion it's almost like the
further you are away from like impact
the decision maker has less and less
impact right
and so uh
a lot of times
scandals and things that we read about
in the news especially in the business
world
most of the time not every time but most
of the time it's not actually the ceo
yes there are these outlier situations
but like it's like oh
a team did something or uh there was
like some weird uh practice that got put
uh some weird hiring practice or there
was some like controversial decision
that was made or whatever and of course
as the ceo like they're responsible
whether they did it or not right like
those two business their business
um
but it's just very
i don't know it's just weird
right and like if you go to like the
military industrial complex stuff like
who's responsible
could we point to one person like i
guess you could just be like oh
leadership 101 like the person at the
top the president united states is
responsible like that'd be one argument
another argument is like
no actually there was like even like a
public private thing like there's the
government then there's all the defense
contractors you know you watched
something like uh war dogs you ever seen
that movie oh yeah he's going on my
podcast tomorrow or wednesday is he yeah
pacquiao's
so like
so like
that's real
right like that whole situation is like
a real thing like who's responsible for
that the government bro are you kidding
me like it's like they wanted the
cheapest
[ __ ] they could get to arm the afghans
right like they didn't give a [ __ ] how
good the guns and the ammo were for the
afghans but they had this this embargo
on china this political
thing they had to yes portray to the
public but like is it when you say the
government right like this is where it
gets into is it the politicians
is it like
i don't know a general who's going in
and like he's part of the legislation or
whatever is it like uh the lobbyist
right there's like all these different
parts to just like the government
and it gets weird because like yeah
agreed right like the government right
and then it's like okay cool who who is
the government right yeah and you're
like actually it's like a little bit of
all of them right right it's kind of
like one plus one plus one equals three
you can't blame the three you gotta
almost like try to break it down it's
very [ __ ] weird it is man i mean
could you it's [ __ ] crazy to me that
there was even a website where you could
just go bid on these federal contracts
like this
but there's pros and cons to that
yeah right like like inside right in
some way yeah it helps small businesses
right and another way
to do the [ __ ] computer do anything
bad really
did they
like they they they didn't really i know
pacquiao didn't make any money he got
[ __ ] but yeah well it goes back to
like
again good intention bad intention right
which again you should ask right
like try to try to unpack that but also
it's like did you know that it was
something you weren't supposed to be
doing
well like uber when they went to new
york city knew that they weren't
supposed to be
providing the ubers because the taxi
medallions and all this [ __ ] but like
they had to push up against the local
regulation right in order to
get people to do exactly so it's like
very weird blurry yeah because and it's
the same thing with war dogs it's almost
the same thing as fire festival like
they got in so deep they got the
contract [ __ ] we got to do everything we
can to to fill up we're gonna give us 20
million dollars we have is this chinese
we're already we're already balls deep
into this deal we have to do everything
we can so repackage it put it in
cardboard boxes and
the reverse is happening right now do
you know uh uh with russia china and uh
oil and like energy this episode is
brought to you by eight sleep good sleep
is a game changer and the eight sleep
pod is the best sleep machine i sleep on
it every single night a great night of
sleep allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new 8 sleep pod
3 you can sleep as cold as 55 degrees
fahrenheit or as hot as 110 degrees
fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself innate sleep you can
go to eatsleep.com pomp today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
hsleep.com not only do i sleep on it
every night it literally changed my life
and i begged the founders to let me
invest in the company
eightsleep.com go get yourself an
eight-sleep pod and get a better night
of sleep so russia i don't know i don't
know the details but i think russia is
getting super rich off china buying
their oil
so yes but
europe
is like virtue we're not gonna buy
russian oil or natural gas right or at
least uh
most russian or uh european countries
are saying like hey we're not gonna do
this we don't wanna support this country
that just invaded ukraine all stuff
so guess who they're buying it from the
chinese oh my god guess what china's
getting it from russia so literally
there's this article i think it was in
like new york times or wall street
journal and it was like russia is
selling their uh uh energy to china
china's just like marking it up 2x then
turning around into europe
which like
again you look at you're like this is so
dumb but then you that's like the global
analysis with all of the information but
you look at each individual decision and
you're like oh okay uh european country
a doesn't want to buy from russia
because they don't want to support this
like situation
okay like i think most people are like
all right like i see that logic i might
agree might not agree whatever like i
see the logic
but then when you're like oh by the way
okay russia's just gonna sell to china
china's gonna market up 2x and now
you're gonna go broke and also uh
potentially freeze yeah
[ __ ]
dude it's so weird everything's about
making money everything is just about
money like it's all about like me and
him were talking about earlier the world
is the wwe bro why do you why do you
think that i know matt thinks that why
do you think that it's just it's all
about [ __ ] gimmicks it's all about
selling gimmicks it's all about per like
selling perspective and like selling
stories that's really what it all is how
do you think about the state of like
media and content today like along those
lines if everything's a story how much
of it is like on the internet away from
the big uh whether it's the disney's the
you know hollywood studios and like the
new york times of the world versus like
those are still very relevant and will
be for a long time i don't know i think
i think
um i don't think that big media
companies are gonna
are gonna be around forever for much i
don't know how much longer but like new
york times and like cable news and for
sure like traditional cable tv shows are
dying on the vine right like like the
reality show boom that happened 10 years
ago with like
pawn stars and duck dining and all that
[ __ ] and nobody watches that i don't i
don't think anymore uh dynasty was
[ __ ] fire when it came doug dynasty
was sick wasn't it these dude's got his
beards and they're rich
america was enthralled yeah it just i
mean it just it's evolving i think the
independent what does it get replaced
journalism wins over everything i think
uh independent journalism like the
people like you and me the people that
are just like have microphones in a room
talking about [ __ ] and invite like like
it's it's a great it's such a it's such
a
natural exchange doing [ __ ] like this
right because we're talking on each
other's shows and we help each other
because we're exchanging our views our
audience our eye the eyeballs the
attention and there's no
there's no conflicting manipulative
outside elements in this right it's just
superna it's natural
um i think a lot about uh you ever seen
like people like oh would you take 500
thousand dollars for dinner with jay-z
you ever seen that like meme on the
internet yeah yeah uh would you rather
be
uh
uh let's say doing documentaries with
the new york times
or would you rather have a youtube
channel with 500 youtube channel 100 are
you kidding like all day
i think i don't know who else i don't
know who would who i think that if you
went and you asked people and i'm
picking on new york times just because
they're probably the biggest from a
subscriber standpoint but like all of
the major mainstream media
and you ask them would you rather
be in your job or would you rather be
with the youtube channel with 500
subscribers i think most of them would
pick the youtube channel too yeah i
think so yeah i definitely think so i
mean i i had i mean i spent a lot of my
life um trying to sell tv shows to like
big tv networks what was that like and
it was terrible i mean it was fun doing
it like i did a couple of big projects
where i spent years like in crazy
situations filming really crazy [ __ ]
like in the
one of them i got to spend like five
years in the caribbean like just to film
a tv pilot and uh then i got to shop the
sizzle to i got to meet with all the
biggest tv networks there are
and um
it ended up being like six years and the
thing got to a green light meeting at
spike tv and the ceo of icom killed it
at the green light meeting and that was
just like
okay where do we go from here like this
is six it's just over it's so it's not
necessarily over i mean you can keep
trying yeah i mean a lot of the issues
but over with spike tv with spike tv
yeah but we had already pitched it to
like every other every other network and
the weird thing about doing it is like
you take this cool idea that you think
is great that you've been working on
forever that you think is exciting and
you pitch it to all these buyers they
all have notes they all want to be like
um make these edits for us we think we
can sell it if you change it this much
all 16 production companies are saying
that same thing
and so at the end of the day you're just
banging your head against a wall trying
to re-edit stuff to hopefully sell it
and get paid for this project you've
been working on for five years and it 99
is not going to go anywhere
and that's how i started my youtube
channels i started just taking the stuff
that i was trying to sell to traditional
um tv networks and packaging it for
youtube and that's why i learned to
start my own [ __ ] yeah how long did it
take for you to realize it was gonna
work
to realize what youtube was gonna work
yeah
like the first video you post how many
views does it get a couple hundred maybe
i was learning i was learning from oh i
i just talked too much my friend i had i
have a really good friend who um
he actually they just sold their company
called dupont registry okay what is that
it's a it's basically like a uh the
millionaires auto trader it's just like
high-end cars and yachts but it's like
the auto trade started out as like the
auto trader for lambos and rolls royces
basically okay and um it was really big
in like the 90s and early 2000s
and they recently just sold it but
i used to work i worked for them right
out of high school for my buddy i was my
friend whose parents owned it so we like
developed all the social media stuff for
them because it was right when companies
decided they needed to be on social
media
so my buddy's dad was like we need a
youtube channel danny you're good at
making videos
so we started getting all these crazy
cars in all the time and making these
sick videos and built a youtube channel
for them
and um so that worked and you were like
okay that worked i learned kind of the
formula there like how it works when i
have unlimited money to do whatever i
wanted to do
and then
from there i left there started working
on like on like developing tv working on
movies and and um
going through that whole rigmarole and
then i went like [ __ ] i'm going back to
square one i'm going back to just
youtube i'm gonna repackage all this
crazy [ __ ] that i'm working on and
posting it myself and just whatever i
think is cool i'm gonna post it online
how much do you think about the content
itself versus like the distribution of
it like driving people to go see it um
in the beginning of it it was all
distribution like i would post a video
and then i would email probably like
200
blogs and websites being like and i
would lie to them i would be like i
would be like yo i just came across this
sick video i think your website viewers
would love check it out or whatever i
would send that exact email to like 100
200 blogs and try to get it and it
worked really a lot of them posted yeah
i had one video
one of the first videos i did uh that
really blew up was a video down here it
was a guy buying a four million dollar
lamborghini veneno
and it was one of four they made one in
like the or no maybe one of three how
many colors are in the italian flag
three maybe three so there yeah so
there's green white and
what's the color red red so there was
one with green trim white trim and red
trim he bought the one with green trim
four and a half million bucks he bought
it down south beach and i filmed like
him getting the car delivered i
interviewed him about it
and then uh
i edited the video emailed a bunch of
blogs about it and the thing had like
two million views in like two days it
was crazy that was the first time i saw
a video go viral i was like watching my
phone
holy [ __ ]
what's the next one yeah yeah and so
what about now
now now it's just posted don't do
anything
yeah now it's just now it's so much
different now it's um it's weird because
we're like in this
podcast world you know it's just like
trying to be i just try to do everything
i can to be different from other
podcasts because there's so many [ __ ]
podcasts yeah everyone's a podcast
so i try to venture out of like the the
typical
podcast guests that like do the
the rotation you know there's so many
people that do so many different
podcasts and i i talk to people that are
interesting that are on like tons of
other podcasts but most of my
most of my podcast episodes that have
been most successful
were people that had never done podcasts
before people that had never been
interviewed on camera before or been in
the media at all before
and
is that something that introduces
volatility so you get some of the
outsized
super viral very popular videos but also
you'll post a video and get no views
yeah yeah for sure i'll i mean
there's a lot of
that that happens for sure um i think
that's why a lot of people don't do it
yeah because it's so it's risky right
like they
the safety net they want to know hey i'm
getting my 50 100 000 views on every
video they don't want to risk i could
get 5 000 or could get five minutes
that's the milk boys model right they
get we're just gonna get the most we got
unlimited money again dana white's gonna
fly and fly in trump or we're gonna go
up to mar-a-lago they're gonna get the
most famous people they know that are
guaranteed gonna get i mean that's the
smart way to do a podcast you know
you're gonna be successful
but i think my
mindset is the opposite i wanna get
people that no one have ever heard of
and
what like when that happens do you see
those people then blow up and go on a
bunch of other products yes yeah one of
the most successful uh examples of that
is this guy matt cox who emailed me when
he was in the halfway house um he was
literally emailing me from the halfway
house right when he got out of prison
he's like hey i want to
uh sell my
book script he funny enough going back
to war dogs he wrote the manuscript for
war dogs what and warner brothers stole
it from him
whoa who is this guy his name is matthew
cox he's a he's uh he was a mortgage
fraudster so he committed tons of
mortgage fraud right like in 2004 2005 i
think
um 2006 right before the collapse
um
and he was on the run
basically what he was doing was he was
renting houses and stealing people's
identities
taking out mortgages claiming he was the
owner of these houses when he wasn't so
he was getting fake mortgage he was
faking his side faking creating fake
people and taking out mortgages under
these fake people's names that doesn't
sound legal yeah okay um
he went to prison for like 20-something
years
and he just said i'm going to become a
writer in prison and he met devaroli in
prison
uh who's the dev ephram devereoli he was
the guy who basically was the
main character of war dogs and um he
wrote devaroli's memoir he basically
like went to his cell every day when he
was in there and wrote his personal
story
and then um
dev rolly got out before he did dev
roley only did four years so devil
really got out took the manuscript and
sold it to warner brothers without math
permission
no way yeah so there's a big lawsuit
that has oh so they're still trying i
think they're still trying to figure it
out yeah and so uh did this matthew cox
he's out now so yeah so yeah he got out
in 2019 the beginning of 2019 so he did
like
he did 12 15 years yeah so yeah exactly
i think he did right about i think he
actually did
i want to say it was 16 years so 2019
minus 16 years that's when he went in so
i might be a little bit wrong on when he
was committing all that crime
but um anyways yeah he was emailing me
right out of the halfway house trying to
convince me to do a documentary about
him or do like a celeb tv show about him
or a movie about him and i was just
basically he was emailing me so many
times i kept ignoring his emails
and uh he's finally
uh
i emailed him back i'm like yo i'm like
we can do a podcast
and see if there's any interest and then
if there's a lot of interest maybe i can
help you in other ways
and he was he was not interested and uh
he was doing he was on work release and
then one day i had a podcast guest who
had to reschedule
and i called matt up from that while he
was in the halfway house i'm like yo can
you get here this afternoon and do a
podcast and he he did it and that was
like one of my biggest podcasts how many
views i think it had like
total maybe like five or six million
views
and why was everyone so interested
because he's just i think i think it was
his personality his just charismatic
he's a really charismatic storyteller
he's a really good storyteller and just
the way he told a story it was just like
watching him talk about his story was
like watching a [ __ ] movie like
watching it catch me if you can or
something like that really yeah it's
fascinating and he so he took that
opportunity and he has created his own
youtube channel now he has like over 50
000 subscribers he sold
thousands of books he was he became the
face of a company called home title lock
so he's now like the brand ambassador
for home title lock he had companies
flying him all across the world like
flying him out to talk to their board
members like he's really
kind of like uh the guy who catch uh
from catch me if you can where he
basically was like hey i did all these
things but let me teach you how to
prevent somebody else from doing yes
exactly got it exactly so he literally
took that opportunity from that podcast
how popular it was and [ __ ] made
built like a little empire out of it
it's incredible yeah
it is so cool to see uh people who
nobody knows kind of blow up yeah right
it's um
it's like a discovery thing i think a
lot about like uh
talent is so innate to everything that
we do in life like if you run a business
you're trying to find people to uh hire
if you're an investor you're trying to
find people to invest in if you're
creating content on the internet in an
interview style you're trying to find
people who are interesting whether
they're known already not known or
whatever and in some way you're like a
broker right you're like trying to find
the guest and then bring them to your
audience
but there's very few people who can do
it where like they're unknown completely
to the internet and those people are
special
yes yeah like when you
and i do think that like sometimes you
like find one we had one in uh the
bitcoin world in 2018 where i remember
we got done with the interview and i was
like holy [ __ ] and i like turned like
bought more bitcoin
yeah i was like dude i don't even know
what you just were talking about but
like that was [ __ ] crazy uh and we
put it out and it just exploded it was
like you put it out within the first
like 30 minutes you're like yep here we
go and it just exploded um
but i do think something about like that
probably happens more often than we
think and it's just um
serendipity right like how did like this
guy just emailed you a bunch
and then another podcast guest didn't
show up and then you called them they
had to be close and like
had it like you could have never set out
to be like let's go find somebody in the
mortgage fraud you know world and like
the top-down approach wouldn't have
worked yeah you're right some of the
best things some of the best [ __ ]
happens when you don't plan it at all
and it just happens like serendipity
yeah and also i think uh
the new york times would have never done
that
right because that person in some way uh
is a risk to the brand
and so like sometimes like the brand
actually prevents you from talking to
certain types of people
right because like there's a stamp of
approval right whether it should be that
way or not it's just
in the eyes of the audience if it's
written about in the wall street journal
they stamped it right they said this is
legit they said you know whatever and
it's why like uh i don't know theranose
people are like oh look at all the
reporters who wrote all these articles
like whatever and they're like you're
supposed to like have the bar you're
supposed to like be the certifier right
which like yes the internet is taking
that power back right and and kind of
saying hey look maybe that's not a good
thing um
but like you and i could bring all kinds
of people have a conversation with them
and the audience would love it yeah
right versus like can you imagine if uh
some of the new york times like talked
to this guy yeah but it's also scary too
because companies like like fake
youtube and twitter are becoming the
same thing right you worry about them
taking your stuff down oh yeah all the
time i mean i i
obviously have to think about it that
sucks having to think about it because
it stifles your creativity you know we
we um
not only think about it like we like
have actively been like should we like
have a plan okay can are there things
that we're not supposed to talk about i
mean that's like a crazy thing to say in
the united states of america things that
we're not supposed to talk about that we
can talk about but we can put on the
platform and like put it in a way where
it won't get taken down
um like how specifically uh
there's certain topics
that uh i personally believe get
suppressed
really
you should talk to somebody who says
something critical about china
and put it on youtube and you tell me
whether you think that video got
suppressed or not
again it's not every video it's not all
this stuff but
rather than say c-h-i-n-a or if it says
c h asterisk n a um
yeah i was talking to somebody else who
was saying the same kind of the same
thing but he was basically saying that
he thinks about his he does long form
podcasts and he's saying that he will
personally put the
um controversial topics towards the end
of the podcast like after the hour and a
half mark
he just thinks that youtube employees
won't listen that far right i guess
i don't know but like having to like
consciously think about that it's crazy
but but it's also like is it just the
controversial topics or like i do one we
had our channel deleted one time
really oh i don't know if you know this
yeah uh we were like on a live stream
and uh uh we were interacting with the
audience doing stuff we had a guest
whatever and then
right uh at the end of the video um the
video ended and i got like an email and
then a second email immediately and the
channel was just gone
and like i got a big enough twitter
following when i just like raised hell
and i was like yo what the [ __ ] was that
yeah and they basically were like oh
sorry like
an employee
made a mistake
and i was like
dude
one employee has the ability to just
like
zap yeah right and that's not on youtube
that's just like every social media uh
platform has this but like we forget
like
what's the better solution right like
how bureaucratic would it become if you
need like five employees to approve it
right so local decision global decision
right
yeah i mean i'm sure a lot of it has to
like there are probably individual
people working from home from you that
work at youtube that they just have to
probably go through and approve a
thousand monetizations on youtube videos
every single day you know i don't i mean
maybe not maybe it's probably ai yeah
you ever read the stories of uh uh the
content moderators at facebook
so yeah i think so a lot of i might have
seen a podcast about this i don't
but there's an article and a lot of them
have like uh at least the early signs if
not the actual signs of ptsd
what
well think about it if um
uh
so there's two groups of folks there's
the content moderators and then also
drone operators uh my wife uh has
written about this before where so like
the drone operators i think is like a
clear example so
you're like i don't know in arizona in
like a
room it's all computers and stuff right
and you're sitting there like operating
a drone that's like somewhere else
and all of a sudden they're like you
know
okay lock's on like uh yeah that's a bad
person or whatever like fire
you hit a button and it explodes that's
weird
and then you like it from this killing
that you're doing yeah then you like go
to like dinner
right right you know what i mean like
it's like a weird weird weird thing
whatever it's like there's been articles
now that are like hey yeah like the
remote drone operators like [ __ ]
crazy world
but also um there there's one specific
video i remember i worked at facebook
for two years and uh
at one point um
there was a video from the middle east
all the details don't matter uh but
basically uh it was propaganda video
where uh allegedly they captured a
foreign pilot
and uh the video was very graphic they
basically filmed uh the killing and
burning of this pilot
it was done in a super like cinematic
way there was music there's all this
[ __ ] and when they got on the facebook
platform it was just replica and it was
almost like a like they call them a bot
farm but it is all over the platform so
facebook this one the first time they
dealt with this stuff right they're like
trying to
say hey this this violates all of our
community guidelines and all this stuff
stuff they're trying to get it off the
platform because it was type of video
where like
i went to iraq i've seen plenty of crazy
stuff whatever like
i was like dude this graphic has video
right like this is one of those videos
that like if your
parent figured i was getting killed
while he was alive like he was like were
they like decapitating him or something
it was like in a desert uh they like had
him in a cage and they like
doused him and they lit on fire and like
like it was like bad right yeah
and so people were replicating this
video it looked like uh to some degree
and again
i understood it because i talked to
somebody who was like working on it but
it looked like almost um
you take a video and you upload it but
if you expect that they're gonna try to
take it down then you have like
50 pages or 100 pages and you post it to
a bunch of them or whatever like they
were almost it seemed like doing it like
an automated
fashion got it so it was like a
whack-a-mole game right
um and so
i remember thinking to myself like dude
there's somebody who like
somebody flagged it they reviewed it
whatever
recently it's come out well there's like
content moderation teams
and they sit all day long and they
review content well if it's flagged for
like violence
it's like people shooting people
stabbings like all like all this stuff
you just sit and watch that all day
yeah you're gonna be [ __ ] up yeah
yeah oh yeah it makes a lot of sense huh
right like imagine if you just watched
like gruesome things that that platforms
decide shouldn't be on the platform and
your job is to just sit there and be
like nope that's good this is not good
nope that's good this is not good
crazy that's a crazy thing i never even
thought about
wow man well twitter allows a lot of
that [ __ ] don't they
so twitter i saw a video on twitter like
a week ago of this dude getting in a
fist fight and then this guy just pulls
out a knife hits him in the neck and
then he's standing there and you just
see blood shooting out of his neck then
he collapses you should go back and see
if it's still there i don't know if you
know like what account or whatever yeah
because i always wonder when i see
videos you know like that
is it just because like
they haven't caught it yet nobody's like
reported it and then what gets reported
it was that guy andy no he posted it he
reposted it you know what i'm talking
about yeah the guy he was like what in
the portland protest or something yeah
yeah yeah i think he got his ass kicked
or something by a bunch of antifa people
or something i i think that he he i
think that happened more than once and
now yeah like he kept going back um
yeah but like that content is just kind
of crazy
mm-hmm
i don't know
it makes you think a lot about the
content that gets uploaded yeah well
it's i mean i mean going back to what
you're talking about about companies
like the new york times and the wall
street journal it's like twitter and
facebook and youtube are essentially
worse than they are
because they're
they're like
the monopoly that controls
all of the [ __ ] media distributors
like they're not just they're not just
the
the
corporation that provides the journalism
they're the corporation that distributes
the corporations that provide the
journalism
so when you're like when you're [ __ ]
dealing with like they don't i don't
like they're just
dealing with their policies or trying to
make [ __ ] conform to their policies but
when you start to talk about like
them censoring stuff based on ideology
you kind of get crazy like it's it is it
sounds good and i want it like i
like
everyone talks about it but it's just
it's hard for me to fathom that they
really
are taking [ __ ] down i don't think again
on a global basis i don't think that uh
the platforms generally are like
all content from one political party
is good or bad
i find like with you i'm like that's
hard for me to believe i've been inside
of one of the companies right right you
work with with snapchat too right yeah
for for a little while and when you like
look at it
it's like at facebook there was
something like a single piece of content
would get shared somebody like hey what
is this or or whatever but it at least
from what i saw in 2014 2015 it was
never like
all good all bad this political party
that political party
but then you look at like take twitter i
never worked at twitter but uh
the hunter biden laptop story yeah
like that again local decision we'll
call it local even though it had a
global impact
local decision in terms of this one
piece of content are we going to allow
it and it wasn't like um he said the fbi
told him not to zuckerberg just said the
fbi is one that they tipped him off like
warned him or something yeah yeah it's
like and i think they i think what he
said to rogan was that they like
suppressed the distribution but didn't
completely block it
which again like
sure
well it just gets into this whole game
of like
i always try to put myself in their
shoes
what should they have done
right and like
it's a complicated [ __ ] world because
guess what if it had been
not the true story or whatever like
basically what they were warned of
then all of a sudden
if you just let everything fly
you know it's like this weird world yes
yes totally yeah you understand so it's
kind of it's kind of like lose lose to
some degree right but with the twitter
thing i was i remember people were like
sharing yourself like i can't dm this
privately to my friend
right you can't even dm [ __ ] [ __ ]
and that's when i was like all right
like this is kind of crazy
it was a new york post article it wasn't
like from what i remember the thing that
was being blocked wasn't like uh uh you
know danny's wildconspiracytheory.com
right it was like
one of the longest standing media
outlets in the country right right again
sure some people don't think that they
do you know real work or whatever but
like
i don't know yeah well i mean
that and the all the vaccine [ __ ] like
that specifically that's easy to type
figure out the motives behind that it's
all money it's like the pharmaceutical
industry pushing their vaccines like
they don't want anybody talking
negatively back about vaccines we posted
a video recently
[Music]
and uh we had a guest on and he was
talking about how we're essentially
moving from
an american-dominated
uh kind of global world order uh to this
like multi-polar world
now multipolar world just means that
like there'll be like the american view
of the world there might be like a
russia-china view of the world and maybe
there's even like uh you know i don't
know whatever other
views of the world but like we're gonna
have multiple
views of the world it won't be so much
globalization it'd be more like
nationalism uh and this is something
that they're talking about on every
media outlet uh we have politicians
talking about it we have economists
talking about it like this is a question
right now are we going to continue with
globalization or are we going to pull
back from that a little bit due to
geopolitical conflict supply chain
disruptions like all these different
things
so this guy was talking about uh
the new world order like falling so he
was saying like hey like this this thing
that people have talked about is like
not gonna be a thing in the future we're
gonna go back to like an
american-centric view of the world and
then other places okay and we titled the
video something like uh is the is the
new world order is the world order
falling
right
and youtube put like a uh a warning or
like a uh i think it was a context panel
into a wikipedia article and it was like
new world order this is a conspiracy
theory by people whatever
and i was like man like sure maybe
there's like an extreme version of it
but like the way that he was using it
was not like
there's five people who run the world he
was using it as just like the way the
world has been yeah is not gonna be the
same way moving forward right and that
was the first time i said to myself i
was like oh they're probably using like
ai or something they just see a phrase
and they immediately put the thing
that's not human reviewed it can't be
right oh cause if you watch the video
you'd be like oh these guys are just
he used a poor choice of words at worst
right
but again you're doing this for billions
of videos like what are you gonna have
you know
100 million people sit there and watch a
couple videos every day right right
right you do that yeah the whole like
view of do you i wonder if if when it
will change when uh humans will evolve
into not thinking like russians
americans chinese
you know and like women do that when the
tribal mentality of humans
will
if if we'll get wiped out before that
happens but i wonder what it would take
for us to evolve into something just
thinking of like everybody is just
humans
you need catastrophe unfortunately you
need catastrophe yeah you probably do
right think about it uh republicans
democrats like all of a sudden those
lines kind of blur and everyone's just
like un-american when there's like
an external threat to america right
right right uh and sure there's some
idiots that try to politicize things
whatever but like for the most part okay
911 was a good example everyone was like
[ __ ] america um
and then like you see like europe comes
together
when the russian ukraine stuff happens
right so like there's this almost like
external risk or catastrophe it seems
aliens would be like a [ __ ] global
alien yo humans first whatever's coming
yeah because politicians political
parties and and governments would lose
their power they would lose the
allegiance of their people they would
lose democrats and republicans and they
would
we would just have earthlings
do you think that aliens are real yeah
of course yeah i think i think i don't
know i think they're real i uh i don't
not think they're real
i for sure think that i mean just from
the people that i've talked to that
so say let's just say let's say that
they exist i think the more important
question is will we interact or discover
them during our lifetime i think they
exist but the thing i don't know is what
are they
okay explain or like where they came
from i think is the question
i think something exists
whether
like whether it's time travelers or
something from another planet
or
um
some sort of civilization living under
the ocean
there's gotta be
i wanna know who's responsible for those
[ __ ] those ufo videos like somebody
advanced is responsible for that
i don't know if it's the
u.s russian or chinese government i
don't think it's
i think it's too advanced
some somebody some tic tac thing someone
else has got to be responsible for that
i don't think it's humans
the tic tac thing is the one uh was it
uh bob lazard right you know this guy is
he's the one who worked at area 51 or
whatever and he was like oh yeah there
was like like disc looking spaceships
like
all right that was like 40 years ago
yeah he described traditional flying
saucers yeah and so like all right you
see the tic tac thing and it's just
again i i'm not a uh uh
what is it like uh expulsion engineer or
whatever right uh propulsion propulsion
yeah propulsion engineer see i told
y'all um and uh uh
when you think of it it's like dude i
never seen anything do that before
like i don't know if you saw a video
recently uh on twitter
and they have like a screenshot it's
this thing that like look appears to be
like flying down uh the sidewalk like
fast
it's like a little light
and uh and there's a screenshot of it
and of course like the way the
screenshot is it just looks like [ __ ]
crazy thing right right and i kept
thinking myself i was like that could be
like a bullet
right they just like the way that the
air kind of behind the board or
something that could be something else
like i have no clue yeah but like i
don't trust any videos i see anymore
no i don't think
no i mean
especially when it's on t even if it's
not like social media you see this one
on social media and it's probably
[ __ ] right if you see something like
a ufo that somebody just posts but if
it's on tv you can almost guarantee it's
[ __ ] because there's so many like
shows like ancient aliens all those
history channel shows they just over
dramaticize all that [ __ ] so much you
ever talked to one of those guys no i i
had an ancient alien researcher
oh really like two years ago uh bruce
fenton i think is his name and uh uh
he
he had me until like the very end and he
was like walking through like the
dinosaurs like all this stuff and all
these theories or whatever and then he
was like at the very end he's like and
by the way they're ancient aliens and i
was like
you lost me on that part but like well
there's like theory behind it yeah up
until some point well here's the demo
there's evidence like there is evidence
of super advanced technology back in the
days of like the in like the egyptian
times like if you actually dissect the
timeline there's this dude who has a
fascinating youtube channel his name's
uh his channel's called uncharted x okay
um and he goes to he's been to egypt and
mesopotamia and i forget the other
places that he's been to but he studies
like
the ancient ruins he studies like the
pyramids and all the different
ruins in egypt and
other areas around the world
and
he
focuses down on like
specific
engineering that was used so one of the
best examples to me is the core drilling
so there's like this basalt
rock that is used for the like those
stones that you see on the pyramids
super super hard [ __ ] rock i'm gonna
sound like an idiot the way i described
it because i don't know i don't know the
specific details
but um
he looks at these giant pieces of
[ __ ] stone like like twice as big as
this entire table
of basalt
and there's clearly like
a giant circular perfectly symmetrical
blade that is cut into them
and some of them they're they're giant
and okay these rocks are so hard that
some of our
most advanced machines today that cut
granite countertops could could not even
cut them especially on that scale
interesting on top of that there's these
cores that are drilled in these rocks
these perfectly cylindrical cores that
are that are drilled out of these rocks
that
in no like
this technology we didn't even have in
the 80s
or the 90s and this supposedly happened
in the times of of ancient egypt
so like he he takes the evidence and
then and then there's pottery
and there's some pottery that is like
have you ever seen a piece of clay
that's molded like on a clay wheel
people like they throw on the wheel and
they make this perfectly symmetrical
piece of clay pottery it's basically
identical to a piece of clay pottery in
symmetry and smoothness but it's the
hardest rocks that exist on earth that
is that if you gave it to anybody today
with the most advanced technology they
would not be able to replicate that
out of that stone
that's crazy unless like unless like
some people argue that maybe they they
they melted it you know kind of like how
we like form concrete with like wet
concrete and then we form it perfectly
yep but
uh
the science behind it is they couldn't
have made that molten and informal yeah
they couldn't have done that yeah so he
he goes deep into this [ __ ] and the only
explanation is that there was some sort
of super advanced civilization that
happened that existed before the
egyptians
that the egyptians basically took it
from them and repurposed it can you
imagine if at some point in the future
it was like hey the aliens aren't coming
they were already here
yeah like we're actually the dumb
version yes
of the people to inhabit
yeah so
that's
probably the most logical thing is what
happened was there was a super advanced
civilization that existed back then
cataclysms came obviously there's like
in ancient texts the bible
um all of the ancient texts from around
the globe there's depictions of
cataclysms of fire in the sky of massive
floods
and this is all vindic this all is
you could interpret it as
um
asteroids or comets
hitting the earth and melting the ice
caps and like making the world flood
and this could easily wipe out a large
percent of the population now if there
was some sort of advanced civilization
civilization and they figured out how to
survive and or escape the planet somehow
um
that's one of the theories that's a
crazy there's no evidence that that
happened but it's it if you look at some
of the technology that this guy ben
from uncharted x has discovered
there's been virtually zero
zero
explanations
for what he's discovered yeah
modern there's no modern technology that
could do what
has been done to those stones back then
even today
i don't have the answers but i love this
[ __ ]
right because it just feels like uh like
almost like a detective trying to like
figure it out mm-hmm it's it's
fascinating just to like that's
to think about
that kind of [ __ ]
really lights my [ __ ] mind up because
it's something that it's just one of
those things i think it's something
that's ingrained deep in in our
primitive brains that we just want to
we're we're just
naturally interested in that [ __ ]
because it's like where did we come from
what what are we missing from this whole
thing i agree where can we send people
to find your podcast
uh on youtube concrete spelled
k-o-n-c-r-e-t-e
that's the main place people watch it uh
actually spotify has been our spotify
audience has been growing tremendously
too so we actually have more people who
watch our episode on spotify weirdly
enough than we have on youtube really
yeah so if you just search concrete
podcast on spotify it's on itunes too
but so like the audio side has been
growing tremendously
it's very interesting yeah why'd you use
a k for concrete because um i had
another so before i started doing
youtube i had a advertising agency and i
got a cease and desist from a company in
california who had the same name and it
was just me and my friend at that time
so we didn't have money to to fight a
lawsuit so we just changed the name and
uh a buddy of mine who was actually in
the real concrete industry
he uh he said hey man there's this cool
domain name we almost bought for our
company but it's just spelled
concretewithak.com
this was like in 2011 or something and
like even back then a dot-com was rare
to have oneword.com and i thought it
looked sick just concrete with a k so i
bought it for like five thousand bucks
and that's a that's that's awesome
there's no there's no like deep
explanation for it just it was available
and it looked cool online it looked cool
there's no better the word looks cool
k-o-n-c-r-e-t-e there's no better reason
to do it than that yeah
and it's not hard to like like when you
see it you know what it is right it's
not like oh what are all those like it's
concrete yeah people misspell it all the
time which probably is not good for like
discovering it on the internet but
whatever i enjoyed talking i'm excited
to uh talk more hell yeah man i i i hope
you're gonna come on my podcast because
i think that'll be a good one i wanna
talk about like crypto and all that [ __ ]
with you let's do it cool all right